our primetime special Conan in Israel is
airing next Tuesday September 19th at 10
o'clock p.m. right here on TBS that's
all of that that's as much of that song
as we can afford anyway I went to Israel
I had a lot of adventures I met a lot of
great people made a lot of friends
here's just a tiny taste of what I was
up to in Israel take a look this is
exciting the entire reason I came to
Israel is behind this door it wasn't
easy and people do not want to tell me
where you live is very tenacious you get
a drink or go to a movie or just walk
around Tel Aviv some people okay
just came over and I have plans your
plans I mean I could come in and make
pancakes tonight I can make you had okay
okay well that's awkward
I know I know if you're thinking Conan
has got game that's what you're thinking
well things really did heat up between
guile and I to see it all be sure to
watch our primetime special Conan in
Israel airing next Tuesday September
19th at 10 o'clock p.m. and check out
all the many Conan in Israel extras at
Team Coco comm / Israel we really have a
blast
you